welcome back to be rockstars this is the
big question it's a show that gives you
too much information about the heinous
violent acts committed by all your
favorite heroes and Tommy I'm not
talking about what Tom Brady has done to
the bills for the past 20 years
[Music]
well yeah I'm Erik Bosse with me today
is Tommy Bechtold welcome back
Oh for those of you wondering where a
Phillip Molina is hey don't worry he's
just taking some time off from being a
big question of rogue theory he's still
around he still is like our boss
controlling our oxygen flow in here we
still hear from him too much we're still
hearing from him lately and we would
prefer it if he would leave us alone for
a little while
right he is like a big brother face just
covering one of the walls the fourth
wall the blue dungeon is just Philips
face it's speaking of whom unless we had
to reschedule this upload today I think
it's Phillip Melina's birthday if it's a
19 no we can't surprise with cheesecakes
you know like like he did so kindly for
me on my birthday so you know go find
him on social wish him a happy birthday
just be extra nice ten today if you were
playing on trolling him or being or
bullying him on social media just hold
off for today and maybe for the rest of
your life and just don't be mean hey
that sounds good to me
well let's get to it Tommy the big
question for you today is which Avenger
has killed the most people who is the
deadliest Avenger oh I feel so powerful
getting the answer the big boy question
today and let me tell you I have been
very excited about this because there's
a there's a certain blind spot in my pop
culture knowledge that is horror movies
I'm very scared very skittish so I did a
little horror research today to create
some tears of our Avengers are good guys
in comparison to famous murderous
villain so I've created five categories
based on the amount of kills and we'll
go through them you know an Eric piece
for you to fact-check me and correct me
I wouldn't dream of it I I welcome it
our first category is a man near and
dear to my heart the Freddy Krueger tear
we call this the Freddy Krueger
participation division these are people
that want to kill they
definitely get excited about killing but
they're not necessarily prolific at it I
mean they get some good kill they're
certainly exciting so let's start first
with this person probably shouldn't even
be in this category we're gonna go with
mantis who has killed zero people
she has stunned some of that OSes army
and endgame she stunned him but they're
not dead she even had to kick one as it
was giving up so she is she is by far
the worst Avenger at killing which
probably makes her the best Avenger at
being a person well you wouldn't say
that maybe she has a little bit of blood
on her hands for that big bone pile on
egos wherever that is on his cranium
good point a good point that might be
there is an element of guilt there but I
think in a court of law
they wouldn't hang any of those murders
on her if this unless she was assisting
Jeffrey Epstein that'd be a different
story she's gonna name names
she's taking everybody down the entire
liberal media is going down because of
mantis mantis ghyslain
let's see ok so number 2 this guy the
number 2 member of the Freddy Krueger
division is he hasn't had a lot of kills
but when he kills he kills with style
and I'm talking about our boy vision
okay
yes hey Paulie bets okay he's got two
kills but boy are they bangers okay
these are all hits there's all filler no
killer
the other way around this is all killer
no filler he has killed ultron our
favorite dancing robot and Corvus glaive
he blasted ultron with the mind stone
sawed him and then I stabbed clave which
is pretty brutal
you needed to stab him because it was
his own he can only be killed by his own
clave so he had to like pay you know but
that was like revenge right cos leave
did that to him so like vision you know
they just got the taste for the
vengeance he likes eating that best
serve cold he's a typical Brit you know
very reserved very polite and then when
you cross him and when he reaches his
bottom line bottom line Bechtold he must
kill you in a very very violent way but
we should point out here that we did see
vision kill a whole ton of Ultron drones
but I think technically with our numbers
we're not counting Ultron's drones
because they're all like appendages of
Ultron we'll count him as a character we
won't have his drones
we will only count one james spader
voiced character
all right so next in art Freddy Krueger
category is Doctor Strange with eight
kills including Lucy and aster one of
the zealots plus seven outriders an
endgame not bad for a doctor whose job
is to save lives eight kills now that's
where ever he incinerated zealots astral
form that's not easy I don't think I
could do that and then he he snared all
of the outriders to the ground let's
remember these kills are done in
self-defense most of these aren't like
straight-up murders they're like one of
us has is gonna die be are you alright I
think we all understand and I think we
can all understand that Freddy Krueger's
kills were done in self-defense as well
he didn't want to get burned again
listen those parents locked him in his
apartment burned him alive and then he
said you know what I'm taking out your
kids and maybe just maybe that was the
right thing to do I don't know sometimes
they say no matter how thin the coin is
it does have two sides the next person
on our list is hope Van Dyne aka wasp
coming in with a whopping 12 kills all
right well state we actually don't know
12 is what we can confirm but she may
have some other ones out there so she's
she's a pretty she's at the top end of
the Krueger scale she killed 12 of
thanasis soldiers an end game we think
probably more most of those occurred
during the female charge you know ladies
oh yeah yeah
ladies night as I problematically call
it
next I hope Van Dyne boyfriend Scott
Lang who has killed 14 at least 14
people major kills him include Darren
cross aka Yellow Jacket and ant-man man
that guy loves to die in things Corey
Stoll is very good at dying and in
movies and TV shows he's like the
American Sean Bean is the American yeah
if he is he's the American Sean Bean you
heard it here first
Stoll is the new bean ant-man also could
call obsidian and at least 10 outriders
that he stepped on when he was giant man
and also to Leviathan oh so like when
when Spiderman gave him the assist he
went back home city and in an ant man
stomped on did he even realize what he
was stepping on cos Spider Man just
pulled him there last second if those
kind of kills I accidentally killed a
bag of peanuts from Southwest Airlines
in my room that I haven't cleaned in
three years all right
so that is the end of our Freddy Krueger
tear I'm very excited to move on to the
next year this is actually a horror
movie I am familiar with I did watch the
first one of these movies this is the
jigsaw tear jigsaw is a game playing
psychopath he basically made escape
rooms before they were cool and he made
a microphone down
he made escape rooms before they were
cool and he put a little twist on it
instead of just leaving and going
getting frozen yogurt most of the people
died and they're like one person Hey yes
some of these escape rooms people might
be dying in we'll never know
well I mean certainly they could get
kovat and die 14 days later without
knowing if they keep going out without
masks guys if you just keep doing escape
rooms I can't help you all right so the
inaugural member of the jigsaw class is
our good friend our favorite web
slinging teen Peter Parker aka
spider-man who has 20-plus kills under
his belt he whoa hold on Oh Peter Parker
who did he kill well he used this iron
spider instant kill mode to use Oh
stabbed all those out writers an end
game no I know what you're saying out
writers do we feel an emotional
connection no but these were presumably
living entities that had lives lives and
wives and husbands and maybe they were
going to a water park on their planet
and that's all because Peter Parker went
mayhem on Pete you will be tried as an
adult and then maybe he should also get
some partial credit for the ricochet
bullet that hit Quentin back yes we
don't know if wits Abeka is for sure
dead there's all these conspiracy
theories think it'd still be alive but
if he is dead you know Peter might get a
manslaughter charge all right next on
our list is Falcon okay Falcon has 25
plus kills not really surprised for a
government agent right he's killed
hydrangeas he's killed guys and
crossbones gang outriders an infinity
war and outriders yeah Plus like all the
missions that he flew before he met
Steve Rogers like presumably the guy has
has taken lives I should imagine yeah
these are the kills that we can confirm
in MCU movies okay these are not right
you know don't come at me about some
comic book from 25 years ago where
Falcon knocked out a bus of
terrorists off a cliff or something like
that I don't care about that
I'm a visual learner if I can't see it
in beautiful 60-inch HD on my TV screen
then it doesn't matter to me guys okay I
own my own car I own to destitution two
sets of bedsheets
I own a mattress our boss gave me for a
very cheap price okay
boy hey I'm happy to help you get some
some better sleep at least I could do
and I think about Falcon probably get
some bonus points in this category for
the way he killed people especially in a
final battle using those wings be like
just stabbing him with the wing those
those great yes stylish he's killed with
machineguns wings oh yeah these drones
this guy is a very jigsaw would be
honored to have him in this category
because of the creative ways that he
kills now the next person in this
category is my personal he's in my top
three MCU characters in general and this
is a thing you would normally associate
with life giving life saving trees are
our friends and yet group has killed at
least 31 people or living things in the
MCU
and he uses things like I don't know
impaling people with his branches low
level malice
good lord like he said he's a true
menace this man he kills he kills what
he asked you I'm sure there's some
strangulation yeah yeah people I've been
choked people have been like poked
through people have been like drag down
and body slam their necks snapped
yeah and he's vicious he does the
barbecue that she does the kebab he
makes her he makes outrider kebabs
he loves it that's like his big thing
okay next person on this list this
actually surprised me that she was so
loud I thought she would weigh up on the
list Natasha Romanoff Black Widow
with 32 on-screen kills and I'm gonna
say somewhere between 40 and 50,000
offscreen kills like I think yes the
filmmakers and creative forces at Marvel
were like we can't show all the people
that she's killed because it would just
be horrific with all of the red-room
training that she's had she's probably
killed people then just horrific ways so
she's killed soldiers Justin hammers
guards Chitauri she's killed Hydra
agents outriders dozens of unknown other
victims
are they victims or are they casualties
of war I don't know and I yeah she's got
a lot of blood on her hands yeah she
shoots people at close range she shoots
people execution-style she breaks
people's necks she kills people with
their bare hands
this is a violent violent woman and I
have a feeling this count is gonna go
way up in the Black Widow movie when it
comes out yeah for sure like and there
was that whole like thing that Loki
hinted at and Avengers were he's like
Sao Paulo
the hospital Drake Hobbs daughter and
now there's a character who might be
named Drake off in the Black Widow movie
what did she do to his daughter right up
we're gonna find out yeah you're right
that number is gonna go way up speaking
of numbers that are probably way lower
just for the on camera but element of it
but are way higher if we count off
screen we've got our final member of our
jigsaw category is Drax the destroyer
with only 33 confirmed kills
maybe a few more in the battle scenes
that we don't we can't quite confirm
where his skills most of them are done
very Drax style very dry very minimalist
hand-to-hand combat with his knives so
this guy does everything subdued right
he's very he's like the most mellow
murderer of all time it's like just a
quick zip with Dave Batista's massive
frame I mean I don't know I'd let him
slice me up any day right come on yeah I
think the way they got to that number
was like you have maybe a dozen on
screen or tenner a dozen on screen but
like it's applied this guy's killed
countless numbers like there was that
number on the screen where said he had
22 counts of murder but that's also just
like what they charged him with I think
he could've killed or it could have been
a fight or something so that's like 33 I
see where they got the number but it
yeah like like Blackwood it's probably
higher oh great all right so now we're
moving into our third tier these are the
you know middleweight champions of the
world of mayhem and murder these are
these are your killers these are guys
that definitely love to kill but they
haven't quite taken it to the elite
level yet this is a Hannibal Lecter
category Hannibal for the capital very
scary movie I watched Silence of the
Lambs when it came out and I will show
you experience for that movie was this
occasionally thumbs in the ears so I
could not see or hear anything that
movie played from start to finish and I
probably watched the screen for less
than five minutes of it so technically I
saw it but I couldn't tell you much
about it sounds of the lamb should be
way more boring than it is but like man
that final act in the basement yeah I
still watch I know exactly what's gonna
happen and it still freaks me out that
ironically is like the one part that I
remember watching was the black or the
night vision glasses part where it's too
hot terrified alright so anyway our
first member of the Hannibal Lector tear
is none other than in my opinion the
villain of Avengers infinity war Peter
quill aka star-lord with 53 plus
confirmed kills using his blaster
blowing up an entire ship killing his
father ego and of course his dancing
moves that destroy drone in the future
in my opinion he certainly humiliated
him to death and he killed the club that
night for sure probably most disturbing
kill would be crushing his father's face
that would probably be you know what I
was most people would consider a tough
day for any family yeah and that's
update you know and I can see why the
numbers might just be higher for Peter
quill because he's like a pirate they
just won't kill people for fun they pile
up those bodies everywhere
whereas Drax is just on his path of
vengeance yes like Drax may just go
after one person and then get caught for
it whereas those Ravagers will get away
from whatever the scene of the crime is
and go off and kill again and again and
again now coming up next is another one
of these characters that these again are
the kills that we have on screen because
I am sure sure that there are more than
these and we do it some of these aren't
just mentioned on-screen kills I should
mention like you did a good job of
bringing up that Drax he was being
charged with those murders so we know
those happen Bucky Barnes Winter Soldier
has two dozen assassinations over 50
years as mentioned in a film so we know
that those so there's 24 kills his total
though is 77 and I feel like it's
probably way higher than that he's got
50 kills through infinity war and then
he had three more an end game plus two
stark parents and I mean this is a tough
one because do you count the kills when
Bucky Barnes was in charge of his brain
and when he was also undermined
are they're all as at the sum of all of
the parts or is this a separate thing
for now I think we're gonna include them
all
so 77 pretty elite 77 kills we're
starting to get some real numbers here
and I think we're right to include them
all because Bucky certainly does he had
that line in Civil War where he goes I
remember all of them yeah so like he has
to carry that guilt with him everywhere
he goes so we should hold them to it I
think so too
if there's one thing I've learned in
life is that when people feel remorse
you should continue to make them feel
guilty forever that is the American Way
now people are gonna interpret that as
my like anti cancel halter message and
that's really that was just me filling
time with the man who launched maybe the
most successful app in all of
smartphones Jeremy Renner aka Hawkeye
with a stunning 89 kills at least we
know when he was Ronan it's anyone's
guess how many people he killed right I
mean yeah we got a little glimpse of it
when he was taking out the Yakuza but
like they had mentioned that he killed a
bunch of cartel members there's all the
Chitauri we still don't know how what
happened in Budapest remember
differently by both Black Widow and
Hawkeye I mean that could just been
nothing but murder or it was a nice
night in a casino I don't know we don't
know why they remember differently next
very lethal character who I'm surprised
he has this many kills because I would
think the isolation element of his
character would keep him from having
this much but I guess he's just a lethal
embattled Black Panther has a hundred
and ten on Canelo he kills he had 90 for
free end game you know he had foiled a
bunch of like militants he like all this
Nigerian militants where he where he
saved those women and there had probably
been a bunch of missions like that and
like there's like great loot comics that
talk about like the different things he
did and he probably did have to take a
lot of lives in his position but yeah I
will say like also like whenever he
releases that shockwave in the end
because like rewatched I think a final
battle that shockwave takes out like a
dozen each time it happens so like you
could imagine this numbers probably way
higher but he's royalty so he'll get it
swept under the rug it'll never see next
up not shocking that this person is on
this list his name is
literally war machine James Rhodes
character name war machine didn't have a
lot of kills I'd be pretty concerned
so penultimate number of the Hannibal
Lecter tears is James Rhodey Rhodes with
a hundred and fifteen kills he's flown
so many missions it's probably more than
that but this is what we can confirm
yeah he uses the obviously the Iron Man
suit at the war machine suit that has
all of those guns and rockets and stuff
so he he has used both himself
physically in the suit and the suit as a
drone to kill yeah absolutely and I
think a lot of his numbers get piled up
specifically during the battle of
Wakanda in infinity war where at some
point those gates spill open and he just
like bombs the crap out of it and like
scores and scores of them are taken out
just in those couple minutes that brings
us to our final member of the Hannibal
Lector tear and this is someone who I
feel like very much like star-lord like
this character probably has killed
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
people that we don't even know about
that is Rocket Raccoon who like
seemingly has very little emotional
attachment to any living thing
so other than Groot and then I mean kind
of nebula so he has a hundred and twenty
on-screen kills at least we don't know
how many of his gunshots are actually
fatal so we can only speculate Oh Sher
Singh goes down also he's very
consistent he kills with his guns so
it's love for the guns he's controlling
on his spaceship probably his best
moment of killing was him and Bucky
taking out people an end are an infinity
war when they were when they were doing
the team-up shooting yeah yeah it was a
nice moment every time he's done one of
those team team ups whether it's with
Bucky or whether it's with fruit he's
the one spraying people with bullets
they're just kind of like spinning and I
guess Bucky has his gun - but like
rockets just like oh I'm not spraying
spraying bullets as they say spraying
and that brings us to pretty close to
the best of the best our second-to-last
category and this category is named
after my favorite sketch comedian and
pretty awful big brother Michael Myers
[Music]
he's not expecting any invitations to
the family reunion that's for sure I had
to watch Halloween
in a film study class in college true
story I skipped the actual in-person
class where we had to watch it and
elected to watch the original Halloween
on DVD where I could again assume my
Hannibal Lecter Silence of the Lambs
pose so again Michael Myers is someone
I'm familiar with from pop-culture
references but I can't say I've seen a
lot of his work up close and personal
thank you yeah the first member of the
Michael Myers tear is water Maximoff aka
Scarlet Witch first thing she killed was
that accent huh in ultra killed it at
least 129 people with metal energy blast
and we would say she's almost artistic
much like Michael Myers in the way that
she kills there's almost elegance to the
the murders you know she created I'm
maybe trying to think of like all the
okay so if we count the deaths in
disease center right she killed
crossbones in this like awful hey so
there's all that collateral damage but
then like I think we forget her and
Quicksilver before joining the Avengers
we're working for Hydra probably killing
lots of people so it makes sense that
it's that high she's a war criminal she
was working for like evil terrorists so
yeah she probably didn't give a crap who
she killed yeah she's killing machine
should kill Proxima midnight as well a
scary Khun fans were devastated
[Music]
let's see here next on this list Wow a
man who represents the American Way
better than anyone I know Steve Rogers
Captain America with a hundred and fifty
three red white he's killed
Nazis he's killed that's not homicide if
they're Nazis it's not boy I guess
technically there's homicide appeal
illegals but like we should you know it
was good
if you kill Nazis that's homicide
because I approve each and every man
under my command owes me 100 Nazi scalps
and he's killed hydrops same as Nazis in
my opinion Hydra what so that's just a
safe word for Nazi it's like you know
nice oh I approve of that as well that's
also a Tom aside Chitauri
don't know them well enough to really
sign off on those kills other than they
were attacking New York City and nobody
messes with New York City I'm not from
there I'm from New York and again we
don't have the same maybe vitriol for
those kills but they are kills
nonetheless and let's just paint a
picture for you of how Captain America
has killed throwing people off buildings
it's blowing them up hitting them on the
head with his devastatingly heavy shield
throwing someone out of an airplane so
what we do know is that Captain America
doesn't think like I I do have to kill
this person but I don't have to do it
dramatically he instead says I will hurl
this person from I make them suffer for
a few more seconds before they die
probably the most devastating way from
brutal impact with solid earth and you
know what you gotta you gotta consider
that this guy has been around for like
you know decades and decades and decades
yes who's frozen in ice but he fought in
World War two like he was killing Nazis
killin I'd like that already some of any
of his numbers was just because he was a
super soldier in one of the deadliest
wars in human history but also there's
just like all kinds of crazy kills happy
there's that one Hydra soldier got
chopped up in the propeller blades in
the first cat movie yeah this guy's got
a lot of blood I always say the only
good Nazi is a Nazi falling from their
death at the hands of Captain America so
it's not enough that they're dead cap
ask me the one to do it
let's see here the next person Bruce
Banner which again as The Incredible
Hulk those are certainly murderous that
he doesn't first banner has no control
so rights are very little control at
least let's see he's killed soldiers
unfortunately he's taking out a few
civilians he's killed numerous Qatari
gladiators outriders we're just gonna
throw I think we said 186 we're throwing
in a hundred just because it's
impossible to truly know how many people
yeah Hulk has killed because as he says
Hulk smash yeah there's periods where he
blacked out and he didn't know how he
get from got from A to B so like we have
to assume when we see him on camera if
he's smashed in when we don't see him on
camera he's still smash it
I don't think Hulk chills is his
catchphrase with the camera yells Cano
next we've got Kimora
good morning Gamora two hundred kills
only handful on screen but she had a
long rap sheet and I mean she was a
child of Thanos so if we're counting all
those half of populations being called
she's got a past as a war criminal yeah
absolutely she had that and guardians
the galaxy their prisoner jumpsuits had
those barcodes on their pant legs and
like hers was by far longer than the
other Guardians maybe four times as long
so if you use the numbers that we had
for drag sand Peter quill yeah you could
rupal it for sure so 200 for Gamora Plus
who knows how many of the other Gamora
is killed
[Music]
yeah and I don't know if we have nebula
on this list because we don't really I
guess she's an Avenger for sure but her
numbers probably right up there with
Gamora right because all the people that
they helped Thanos kill I would imagine
nebulas probably just a little less than
Gamora just to piss off nebula
so Nabil is probably up there in the in
the 198 199 and every time she almost
gets catches up Gamora kills that person
instead yeah maybe
Michael Myers tier of killers is Carol
Danvers aka Captain Marvel aka the love
of my life brie Larson who has 500 plus
kills 38 Korean scrawls in Captain
Marvel which is just an absolute stat
number for your own movie hundreds on
Thanos ship as well as dozens of kills
as a Kree super soldier
you could argue despite to her thinking
of herself as a like universe
peacekeeper Universal peacekeeper she
actually kind of skews towards war
criminal and the you know acting as a
Kree operative obviously we know in
Captain run with the Kree use all
elements of mental manipulation to make
her think that she is fighting on the
side of good and she only truly learns
the the reality of the situation at the
end of the movie and that's you know
it's hard to blame someone for thinking
they're doing something for a good cause
when they're really not
so I and I think that big numbers for
her come from that moment in-game was
she just smashed through Thanos his ship
that's like their Death Star in that
moment and like I I remember I look this
up at one point if you compare that to
like a US aircraft carrier those have
several thousand people on it 2,300 crew
for you know the average carrier now you
could argue that US maybe took everybody
who's working on that ship and put them
on the ground level because it was like
ultimate stakes you can't spare any
soldier and maybe it's a more efficient
ship than like our Earth's ships are and
it could run with the crew of 12 but
like you can imagine there's at least a
couple hundred on that ship alone when
she blew it up so killing machine Carol
Danvers now this is our final category
these are our top two murdering
at first in the MCU and what I like to
call the Jason Voorhees category if you
look someone actually made a list on the
internet they went through all of these
oh the cool seminal horror movies
child's play saw Nightmare on Elm Street
Friday the 13th and Halloween who is
Jason Voorhees has the most on camera
kills of any of the big killers which
was a surprise to me I would have
thought Freddy but Freddy for some
reason his numbers per serve this might
be a great new rockstars video for us to
make where we factor that and go after
them yeah so Phillip if you're listening
oh he's listening he's watching too
Jason Voorhees this is the grand a this
is the Super Bowl our runner-up our
second most prolific killer in the MCU
is I love you 3,000 Tony Stark Iron Man
with 872 at least kills he had 351 pre
endgame let he took out 16 outriders
plus vanos which should count as a
million kills really yeah then three of
the black order plus 500 remaining
soldiers because he snapped his fingers
and they turned to dust
and of course himself 500 for sure an
estimation but we got imagine a lot of
fan OSes army was already taken out when
he rained fire from his ship he killed a
lot of his own forces and I don't think
it was more than a thousand to begin
with so if you just assume that that
took out at least half there's probably
about 500 left in the ships the
Leviathans the ones on the ground seem
to there is at least around 500 yes and
even if you take those numbers and beef
him up a little bit he's not coming
close to the all-time champion mr.
murder the granddaddy of them all the
greatest murdering force in all of
Marvel Cinematic Universe Odin son Thor
Thor Thor 3363 at least kills so just
going through it in in the first Thor
movie he battles the frost giants so we
see all these other battles in Thor the
dark world he's an Anaheim
Anaheim Anaheim Buena Vista at the
Pirates dinner theater show then he goes
to port ellos for a hot dog yeah
then he checks out in the actual game
and I was a good time but you also gotta
count all the Dark Elves that he fought
all the soldiers down in the in the
crypts of Asgard
yeah then we get to a ton in Ragnarok he
piles him up in Ragnarok he goes in a
murdering spree then we have to remember
the simple quote that he said I've lived
1,500 years and I've killed twice as
many as that now oh yeah how do we I
mean let's take him at face value Thor's
not a liar you know he's certainly he
certainly is confident but I don't
wouldn't say he's the type of person
that feels the need to exaggerate so
that's three thousand right there right
and that's not the idea I think it's
that's I kill you three thousand yeah
and think about it like that's just 2
per year we've seen him killed 2 per
second yeah you know like that makes
sense to put adds up to per year that's
a slow year for him for sure took a lot
of years off periods of no murder
so yeah that's a way I want to mention
it's Buena Park not Buena Vista in a
time so don't wait a Vista that's the
street in Burbank all their studio
before they became Disney Studios anyway
would knowledge for you guys the
industry's crashing right now so that's
it we can all agree probably as number
one kill was winning decapitated Thanos
was Stormbreaker that was certainly for
me the most poignant murder of all of
the kills the Thor has on screen and it
was the closest to like a true axe
murderer style like Tony snapped his
fingers and threw some cosmic Devine
process just cause people to erase from
existence Chris Fordyce picked up an axe
and lobbed off a character said and it's
thudded to the ground and rolled like we
were in the 14th century during turn of
the game of Thrones suddenly because of
this crazy ax murderer
that was the murder that would make
Jason Vorhees proud for sure so before
put on the hockey mask buddy you're the
craziest psychopath and all the MCU so
that's it
well before we continue we want to thank
some people helped us make this show
starting with our friends expressvpn who
helped sponsor this episode thank you
guys now all of you watching you know
about the Steve Carell version the
office you probably also know about the
Ricky Gervais version of The Office that
is based on but did you know that there
are nine other countries with their own
versions of the office that you have
never seen because I didn't I had no
idea I thought there was like one or two
other ones but they're everywhere the
reason you'll note about them is because
they're probably not available in your
country because these stupid like
telecom rules they're different in each
country because we don't have our
globalist world's government yet we're
on our way we're getting there yeah but
in the meantime you can access content
available around the world with no geo
restrictions when you use Express VPN
expressvpn lets you control where you
want those sites to think you're located
you can choose from nearly a hundred
different countries gave you access to
content that isn't available in your
region so if you like watching shows or
movies expressvpn is a must-have for
less than seven dollars a month
expressvpn lets you access thousands of
news shows and movies on Netflix Amazon
Prime Disney Plus tons of other
streaming services it's a no brainer and
it couldn't be easier to use just fire
up expressvpn on your APRA computer or
TV select a location hit connect x
recipe and is also incredibly fast
doesn't slow down my connection at all I
can stream other content HD quality no
issues at all so get the most out of
your streaming services today and
expressvpn comm slash big q and if you
use my link e you'll get an extra three
months of expressvpn for free again
that's expressvpn comm slash a big Q
Express cbn.com slash big Q to learn
more now we also want to thank our
friends at bespoke posts for helping
sponsor now if you're anything like me
you're getting a lot out of deliveries
and mail right now but most of that you
know it isn't much fun it's bills and
coupons paper towels I need to mop up
the salsa I can't stop tripping all over
my apartment I'm sorry sorry but once a
month I have a reason to be stoked and
that's because of my box of Awesome from
bespoke post but smoke post sends guys
only the best stuff every month and no
matter what you're in
- box of Awesome has you covered from
style grooming goods bar we're cooking
tools outdoor gear awesome box of asanas
carefully builds collections for every
part of your life I got the Coast box
which came with a great summery linen
shirt and a waterproof beach wallet I
haven't used any of it you know the
beach yet but I can confirm dat at some
point I will go to the beach and I can
also confirm that that wallet is salsa
proof that's a big deal and they've got
a new box called Terra that comes with
this really cool Japanese utility knife
all natural soap a bird collar box
optimist a cymbal fly me Amy so to get
started take the quiz that box of
awesome calm your answers will help them
pick the right box of Awesome for you
and they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel anytime
each box only costs 45 bucks but has
over $70 with a gear in it get 20% off
your first monthly box when you sign up
that box of awesome calm and enter the
code big question at checkout that's box
of awesome calm code big question for
20% off your first box nice nice
I'm excited well then we're gonna move
on to some bite-sized questions that I'm
gonna answer oh please cuz I don't know
what they are the bite sized at you this
week I hope you're hungry civilian on
our discord s can you exit the matrix
via cellphone and if not how will the
lack of landlines affect the new Matrix
movie if it doesn't take place in
current time that is a great question
that is a very good question so yeah
human hackers do require hard lines to
hack into the matrix because you know
those hard lines are wired into the city
infrastructure in a back in the late 90s
and early 2000s that's you know how most
cities and buildings were wired because
that's how they the grid you know in in
the Wachowski vision of this universe
the grid is basically assembled by the
matrixes
computer algorithm so that's how they
hack in is through that grid but the
weird thing got cell phone signals and
they do use cell phones in the original
matrix they're encrypted they're only
accessible between the caller and the
receiver like sure authorities can
monitor cell phone use in all kinds of
scary ways they can use your smart
phones to track you via GPS services and
apps they can determine how long you're
on the phone with someone and who you're
calling they just they don't always know
exactly what you're saying in that phone
call but at that point they already know
plenty about you and what you're doing
yeah but that's why they make short
phone calls with each other
while they're on the move in the matrix
so I wonder if let that whole idea of
your of your cell phones following you
and listening to you that might be like
part of the matrix for plot like that's
a really cool like technology
communication technology has
revolutionized since the late 90s and
that would be really cool if like matrix
four justifies that in the modern era
they're like the reason why we don't
have phone booths everywhere anymore or
fewer people are in landlines that's
like the matrix like updating itself
being like okay well we're just we're
not gonna have these holes anymore we're
gonna plug all the holes and now
everyone's just gonna use their smart
phones or whatever to talk to each other
[Music]
because now more and more people having
smartphones and maybe that's why is the
matrix planet this way yeah that's
that's my guess
so you are right I don't think people
will hack in the matrix with their
phones unless maybe they like apparate
next to a internet router or something
like a Internet routers still plugged in
to the grid in a way even though that
doesn't make any more sense than just
showing up next to like a phone booth
but III do think that it's gonna be
harder for anyone if they do set it in
the modern era too and I think that's an
interesting challenge for the hackers to
have to find these view landlines that
still exist moving on
also from discord our friend Jay mayor
Jay Marais jamadar asks could Peter
incorporate Edith's capabilities /ai
with his suits and if so is she just
gonna forget about Karen come on
who could forget about Karen I don't
know Tommy I think we should kind of
forget about the Karen's these days
because I'm kind of ready to move on
from the Karen's it's true how about you
you being a [ __ ] is gonna help well to
answer your question Peter suits do
already have most of the capabilities
that Edith gave him like you know in
homecoming that suit gave him access to
a criminal database he has you know
x-ray vision kind of heat signatures
surveillance modes but the difference
from what I could tell appears to be
access to these drones and control over
the drones from the satellite but also
like a few steps forward and mirroring
people's real-time smartphone use like
you could see what they were texting
even before the text was sent they could
just like read what was there writing
into their phones III don't think
Karen's AI could do that but I think the
real benefit of those sunglasses that
you can wear them around whenever you
want and discreetly access all this
stuff without having to put on your suit
like that was a big reason Tony had them
an infinity war is he didn't have to
suit up in his Ironman suit he could
just like already do a lot of what he
needed to do just by walking around I
mean he wasn't trying to hide himself
whereas Peter Parker is he's like a
teenager who's on a you know school trip
he doesn't want to have to like suit up
in order to access the stuff so for sure
to answer your question Peter could
incorporate eNOS OS
to any new suit he has I'm going from
this from an emotional point of view
like he could keep you could bring back
Karen's voice but like Karen was there
in 10th grade you know Karen was his
tenth grade friend who kept giving him
advice on his crush on Liz and now
Peters moved on to a new girl so like I
don't know if you would want that friend
to be like so how's Liz doing like more
stop I remember you know so I would
expect maybe even in the third movie he
doesn't even use Edith he has like a new
AI or personally I would prefer if he
doesn't have any AI like I wanna see
Peter Parker in a true situation where
like he can't really use the suit or
he's like you know cuz he's been outed
what if his suit and his tech gets
confiscated and he has to like work
through that rather than cuz you know
we've had some fun with Tony Stark you
want to make a new Tony Stark surrogate
you can there's plenty of characters and
ways you can do that let's let Peter
Parker be Peter Burke yeah absolutely
that's what he should be yeah all right
finally Dark Knight fan on Twitter great
name and I'm a fan as well you're the
one in ant-man when Scott Lang is
trapped and Darren crosses trap why
couldn't you just get bigger to escape
hmm because that screenplay was barely
written no it was a poorly read Hannah
McKay is an Oscar winning screenwriter
he's a far better screenwriter than I'll
be in my life okay so I did rewatch the
scene there is a moment where Scott
tries to smash like his tiny body
through that glass it's never really
said what the properties of this
container is but he bounces off that
glass I think that moment it's got
realizing that this came container must
be like reinforced
he's trying out its structural integrity
and then I moment he realizes oh I can't
just get bigger and blow out of this
thing and my thinking is that maybe
Darren cross designed this container
because he's testing shrinking in it
right like so maybe he wants it to be
able to contain anything that might
accidentally resize chaotically and it
just like blocks that from happening but
what Derrick Ross doesn't know about are
these Pym discs like Derrick Ross knows
about the ant-man suit I don't know how
much he knows about the discs those are
a separate accessory that hank pym kind
of like uses secretly when it was to
shrink his car or carry a tank on its
keychain
their bits sneakier so that's what scott
uses an
and he takes out a couple of those discs
and he throws them on the glass plating
making the the plating that structure
like bulletproof whatever it is so big
that it blows up the container so that
he could quickly out you know grow out
of it and it really it should have
killed him like most of the things in it
in this movie should have killed him
there's all kinds of problems with this
scene and really I think the issue is is
we just never got a good sense of what
the stakes of his capture were we just
saw him and we just assumed that he
couldn't grow out of it but there's
there's a lot of that in that movie it's
as Otto Octavius says to Peter Parker
brilliant but lazy and that's why it
ranks so low for me on my list I think
it's super funny it's just like yeah
they could have done a bit more to
explain this [ __ ] but they did it's a
lot of funny little parts in it but as a
whole movie it's not it's not one of my
faves all right we have time for one
final question
from the Box craps yeah we're gonna get
personal here all right our question
this week is what is the most
inappropriate moment you could not
control your laughter I have two of
trying to decide I think the most
inappropriate though for me was after
the sound really sad and it is a little
sad but it's very funny my my
grandmother remarried after my
grandfather passed away this really nice
guy named Bill and they were married for
about I want to say maybe 10 years and
then bill passed away she's very sad so
there was a funeral we went to the
funeral and I've covered a huge family
so I have like like 35 cousins on each
side so there it was a lot of kids at
this funeral two of my cousins Alec and
Pat were very little and they just were
little kids in church which is always
the recipe for disaster
so the eulogy is occurring and all of a
sudden they start going this is when
wrestling was very popular open up a can
of whoop-ass and that's tough
open up a can of whoop-ass and then
later on they started randomly singing
that song war huh good god y'all what is
it good so we're all you know like my
dad is sitting next to my grandmother
who just lost her husband and we're all
like I can remember like digging our
hands into our legs to try not to laugh
as these little kids are just yelling
out open up a can of whoop-ass in the
middle of this funeral to say that it
was inappropriate is an understatement
and to say that we were laughing
uncontrollably would be accurate so
that's mine oh you know mine is the very
similar it was also a laughing at a
funeral so when I was a kid I was I grew
up Catholic and I was an altar server oh
yeah so you know how it is and so when
you're an altar server you are put on
the schedule you put on the rotation you
go up like every other Sunday or
something like that but if you're really
good at it they they ask you to come in
altar serve funerals which are a bit
harder there's more things to remember
and they'll slip you five afterwards so
it's great you can make a little bit of
money because sometimes I'll have to
take you out of school and it's because
it's a delicate thing they don't want
like idiot kids mess it up so they so
they get they get the good ones and you
get we get a little money on the side so
there was I did it all the time and then
me and my friends we would just like
screw with each other and try to make
each other laugh during it but we had to
be really careful because the way our
church was laid out we were we're right
next to the family in the front row and
they're always like going through such a
difficult time right so we're just like
little [ __ ] 11 year olds who are
doing this while trying to be respectful
but not at all and then there's this new
kid on it and there was a girl that I
had a crush on named Portia and my buddy
was what's new this is his first time so
he was like I'm gonna get Erica cuz I
hear he does this so nice he'd make fun
of me for having a crush on Portia
because he said that she had a stink
face because she was always just like
mad looking but I thought she was
you but I thought she was like
mysterious and cute he's like nah she's
always she's like pissed off all the
time I don't get what you like her so
during the during the funeral right in
the middle of very quiet moment someone
in the back of the church burps loud and
my buddy leans over to me and whispers
in my ear he goes it was just like
turning P red and was it was so cheap I
want to say like he probably used his $5
to pay off someone to burp so he could
do it everybody passed him but I lost it
and like it was real bad the family did
look over at me and they're like why is
he being such it like I kept like
holding but they could tell that we were
just goofing around and I I was not
allowed to alter serve another funeral
for a while he's a little jerk he got me
good
gotcha yeah for sure he guy Portia she
saw dead people and that's why she was
always frowning as she was just looking
around
yeah she was just one of these haunted
kids well that is our show so great to
chat with you Tommy great job ranking
those deadly Avengers for us good
information they're watching movies now
reminded everyone watching that you can
join our official discord by becoming a
patron at patreon.com slash and rock
stars you can get an audio version of
the show by subscribing to new rock
stars big question wherever you get your
podcast you can send us your big
questions on twitter using the hashtag
big question or by mail and I said RPO
box you can follow me on instagram @ EA
box follow Tommy at Tommy Bechtold
and follow new rock stars on socials and
subscribe here on youtube you get too
much information on all of the stuff you
care about Tommy don't look behind you
or dulu watch out for words coming up
with his ass
Oh
[Music]